And, and it's so much fun
to do. I love playing the,
the straight guy cohost to his
fucking insane character. But uh,
yeah,
we've done these live shows and they're,
they're really a lot of fun and
he's just a, he's a great guy.
Fucking,
oh my God,
it's so ridiculous.
He's got to stay and look at those pants.
That is hilarious.
Did the places like packed and it's crazy.
You guys reading? What are the notes?
Oh, he, he wanted us to, he wrote,
he wrote like a,
almost a play,
but it's all just kissing chips ass and
how wonderful chip is and how thankful
we are going to be there.
Like it's so God damn funny.
I love it. He's a, he's brilliant man.
He's just a great guy and very
fucking funny. I knew from the first,
I think that also a kind of,
I'm not blaming Jimmy or anything,
but I think that helped to kind of
break up the o and a show in time.
I think opie started resenting the
little bit of that comradery that me and
Jimmy were having.
Um,
me and Jimmy kind of slowly
started pulling away and
doing our own thing like it
was, and the humor is, you know,
the more twisted the better. I
love sick humor. He does too.
And we laugh.
We did a whole bit on,
on like Lacy Peterson and Scott
Peterson the murder. Yeah.
And you would think like,
obviously he murdered his pregnant
wife and dumped her in the ocean.
What could possibly be funny about
that? Well, people wrote tribute songs,
uh, with this guy wrote a tribute song
to her and it another one of these self
centered assholes that thought he was
going to go viral by making a attribute.
And we started changing the words to the
song to make it just horrible involving
seaweed and things. So it was terrible.
But me and Jim are literally crying,
laughing and all of these just kind of
sitting there like not really able to
jump in or not kind of getting why
we're laughing at this sick shit. Uh,
so it kind of pushed us further
apart, um, at that point. Yeah.
We,
we both as people changed over the course
of the 20 years we worked together 20
fucking years with any
body. Dude is, is nuts.
You get a girl at Suck Your Dick Every
day for 20 years, you're going to be like,
Oh fuck,
stop sucking my Dick.
But now it's think it's open
across from me, you know? Yeah. Uh,
so you're going to get
on each other's nerves.
And I'm not innocent in the
whole thing either, but I was,
I'm a lot more laid back.
Like I,
I knew what real work was.
I worked for fucking living.
I did heating and air
conditioning installation and
it was freezing cold in the
winter and boiling hot in the summer.
And when I got that first gig
and radio because of Opie,
and I'll always thank him for that.
Uh,
I knew what it was like to work
and I didn't want to fuck that up.
So I plastered a smile on my face at
every turn and did the show four hours a
day. Everyone has someone at work
that they don't get along with.
You don't leave the whole fucking,
you know, you just deal with it.
And that's eight hours.
I had another 20 hours of the day that
didn't involve Greg [inaudible] Hughes so
I could deal with it.
Uh, he was more like,
he had an express himself a little more,
which I guess is healthy in a way, but,
uh, I didn't need to, so I didn't, I
didn't text him. I didn't call him.
I, uh, we got in an argument
once and he goes, dude,
you never even been to my
house. And I go, alright,
get everyone from the show in here. Jim,
have I ever been to the house? Nope.
Travis? No. Sam, no. Iraq. No,
I've never been to anyone's house.
Let me tell you something right now.
Yeah, that's somewhat, chick would say,
I know that when my house toad,
it's exactly that.
Been to my house type of relationship.
Does that mean we didn't see even moon?
I never been Africa. What the fuck are
you saying? I'd never been to Spain.
What does that have to do
with anything that we've,
if you had a problem with
me not coming to your house,
why didn't you ask me to come to your
house? Yeah. Like is there like a,
you asking me every day and I'm saying no.
Everyone. I was saying no. Right, right.
What's going on it, it was always
something like that. And believe me,
I'm not going to sit here and shit on
the guy. I that my shows for that, uh,
I'm not gonna fucking around. Uh,
I'm not going to sit on the guy.
But there were definitely personality
quirks and that, I guess we both had,
but there was something like if,
if I,
I would party all the time and,
and you know,
I had to be there at 6:00 AM
and I'm driving from Roslyn
Long Island to New York
City. It's, it's 25 30 miles of
just fucked traffic every day.
He has to get there.
It could be 35 minutes.
It could be an hour and a half based on
if someone's pulled over on the side of
the road, some asshole crashes in
Queens, whatever it was. It was, uh,
it was a shit drive every day
and you had to be there at six,
right at six o'clock the show started.
And so even at sixth it'd be that
kind of traffic. Yeah. Yeah. There's,
it wasn't as bad as it got it, like seven
or eight, but you never really knew.
It could, it could. I was never late late,
but there were times I'd come in at five,
after eight,
after six was pretty much as
late as I would, I would be.
It was never more than that.
But he would go like,
he never had to say anything like this
music starts, there's a little, uh,
bumper at the beginning, and
by the time it starts, I,
I'd sit down and he and Mike would go,
um, well, I guess there was traffic,
Anthony just getting in and other
bosses are listening. And it was,
it just wasn't necessary to do that.
You know, it, it kind of, I was like,
guys don't do that guys don't do that
to each other. You fucking sit down.
Don't say a word. No one
would know I'm late. You know?
And that's what happened. And it, there
were instances like that. All the,
it's all in my book, permanently
suspended. There's that book out now.
It's out now. Borders,
border's Barnes and noble.
I think we have a copy of the
agreement. Ah, yes. Very good.
But I talked to my house,
it's in my house.
I talk a lot about obviously
the relationship and, and uh,
with opie and, and how it kind of
slowly, uh, came apart at the seams,
I think toward the end.
Uh, he just, it had,
if he didn't want to do a show with,
with me anymore,
I don't think you want to do a show with
Jimmy either. That didn't last long.
And I knew it wasn't going to last long.
They,
I was the buffer between the two of
them. That ended bad. It really did.
It really did. Uh, if you talked
to Jimmy about it, like yeah, yeah,
he doesn't, he doesn't
express that kind of, no, no.
He doesn't like Jimmy's a
very loyalty driven guy.
Like he takes that very seriously and
if he feels somebody fucking with him,
he really gets pissed.
Uh,
usually it can get talked
out and everything's cool
after a little while. Uh,
but this one who follow this,
this is pat. I didn't work.
Yeah, no, I think honestly the way
you guys interacted with each other,
what he was good for was sort
of directing the whole thing.
That's the impression that I got and I
mean how many times I do the show dozens,
right? Yeah. Yeah. I don't know how
many times it did it. Absolutely.
But I was felt like what he did really
well was like sort of guide things like
sit back more, let you guys
be funny, but, but guide,
like figure out like maybe we need more
of this, maybe we need more of that.
And there was real value to that.
Absolutely.
But do you think that's fun when you go
out and do an appearance and everyone's
clamoring about a bit that me and
Jimmy did or something for handyman.
Yeah. And he's sitting
there going like, well I,
I pushed a button and I drove
the ship and I, you know,
went to spots and if he knew it's,
it's,
it's funny cause like, yeah, you're
not going to be appreciated as much,
but it's like a guy who is good at
defense. He doesn't score a lot of points.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. You're not going
to be Lebron James. It's necessary.
Guys who score the points though or the
ones who everybody wants to talk to.
You ever see a, I think of OFI like, um,
do you ever see the prestige, the
movie, the prestige, uh, with the,
the two magicians? No. [inaudible] it's,
it's a good movie. It's a good movie.
But at one point,
because he has to use a body double,
the actual magician has to drop below
the stage and the body double comes out
and gets all the applause
and he's under the stage.
The real guy that did the whole act is
under the stage and he shuts his eyes and
puts his arms out. Like trying to
enjoy the adulation from the fans,
but it's not even him getting it.
And I think that kind of
mindset was there. There's,
and then resentment starts bubbling up
and you start doing things like saying,
Anthony just got in, um, you,
you hold things over people's heads.
The contract negotiations
were a nightmare every time.
And opie always wanted a one year deal.
I'm like, what the fuck are you doing?
Let's sign for 10 years. Who gives a
shit? You know, if they want to fire you,
they're going to fight anyway, the
contract or not, but let's lock them in.
So if something happens, at least
we have, uh, a settlement portion,
we could take half the, the what they
owe us for five years, whatever it is,
not one year deal.
That's all I want.
Because he always had
this delusion of grandeur.
Like there was always something
better waiting, uh, for us to grab up.
And it's like the truth of the matter was,
the glory years of the ONA show were
gone. The New Year's and the, you know,
all that crazy fucking radio.
We were damaged goods after the sex
in Saint Patrick's cathedral debacle.